[Music]
billy eilish opens up about why she
initially hid her bleach blonde hair
dude
here's the thing bro the 19 year old
singer debuted her new look
last month and on saturday billy
answered a few fan
questions including one about why she
concealed her blonde
do before the big reveal writing quote
because it took six weeks to accomplish
this was
the first round too long though but it's
okay as you can see after the first
round of bleach
billy's hair was blonde on top and a
reddish orange on the bottom
billy was most recently seen with her
two-toned black and green locks
at the 2021 grammys in march where she
performed her hit song
everything i wanted and took home a
whole lot of grammy gold
a few days later the grammy winner
showed fans that she ditched her
signature neon green and black hair
posting
this shot alongside the caption pinch me
i'm like through the roof bro i'm just
i'm just happy about it
and a few hours after the big reveal
billy cryptically shared
this tick tock video slightly pulling on
her green and black hair
to seemingly show it was a wig fast
forward to saturday
billy confirmed to a fan that it was a
wig she was wearing on music's biggest
night
posting this pic clutching it
[Music]
stop what the hell are you talking about
on friday she showed off her freshly cut
hair in this insta video
and when a fan asked if her hair feels
damaged after all the bleach
she said it's quote healthier than it's
been in a long
time of course billy is all about
evolving her look
i like to be judged so i wanna i wanna
see heads look up
when e.t chatted with her in 2019 she
said she likes to get people talking
it's really sick it's kind of exactly
what i want people to care about
you know yeah like i don't know the
things that
the people sort of know me for are all
the things i want to be known for if
that makes sense because style has
always been something i care about